les castors ont la dent dure et les
propriétaires du moulin de monthoux sur
cher le constate depuis plusieurs
semaines quatre arbres des peupliers ont
été abattus et ont dû être débité aux
frais du propriétaire technique de du
castor 7 vers des tailles crayon mais
c'est exactement comme un crayon taille
et avec un taille-crayon ça veut dire qu
il taillé en pointe et au bout d'un
moment il reste plus haut que sa taille
sa possibilité taille et il reste un
petit morceau et l'arbre tombe bien
évidemment et on est obligé de le couper
de le débiter naturellement tout ça
coûte
s'il y en a beaucoup ça représente une
petite fortune
mais si les frais de vienne conséquent
le terrain est privé pourtant le maire
de montaut sur cher est conscient de la
gêne et la gestion de l'eau des cours
d'eau fait partie de ses prérogatives
il faut donc aujourd'hui traiter le
problème trouver des solutions avec le
privé et
alors là je ne sais pas trop quel
financement on pourra mettre en face
parce qu il est là le problème le
financement d'autant que à proximité à
mareuil sur cher une viticultrice
organise des rencontres viti caster
autour du vin et des casses peur pour
elle
ils ont leur place sur les bords du cher
c'est quand même un bon élément pour le
biotope c'est pas un niveau des racines
qui va attaquer donc il va attaquer au
niveau de la base il va prélever le
ragondin va permettre de re cp de
reformer et de faire repartir des arbres
qui ont été prélevés de le faire
repartir plus fort encore notamment au
niveau racinaire une certitude le castor
s'est invité dans le loir et cher il ya
quelques années il s'invite désormais
dans la vie de certaines communes